Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier!
And welcome back to clustertruck!
Now the last time you saw me play this was on a livestream.
Which meant that you got to see the
~unbridled~
unfettered
Fradalilaia (Words Mark)
UNFRUNGILATED
(Good job Mark)
Catherine (His editor) put up a definition of unfrungulated.
(Thank you)
Rage against the developers!
and admittedly it might of been unfair.
So I'm gonna play this again and I'm gonna tryyyy
*inhale*
To play some of the CUSTOM maps that they have available.
and they have a WHOLE LOT!
They have a whole lot
'Cause people love this game...
*annoyed Mark* For some fuckin' reason ._.
But I'm gonna play it for you guys <3
But don't expect me to be any happier about it >:(
I'm probably still gonna be
*deep inhale*
REALLY PISSED OFF
But I got -- I don't have any maps
KPFT
WHA-- WHY DID I ASSUME THAT I WOULD HAVE MAPS LOADED UP HERE?
I didn't even download anything!
I'm not ready for this episode to start!
eHAHA I'm an idiot :(
WipeOut
Dancing Dunes
Secret Forest
The sun
Mario :D
That looks like a boob
I'm gonna get that one :)
ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Medieval Madness
Alright that's enough
That's enough!
Ok let's did they
LOAD?!?!?!
NO? I GOTTA RESTART THE GAME DON'T I?
vvvuuh Fuck (Calm down Mark)
Habuski!
HEYYYYYYYY! It worked :)
Ok
So we're just gonna go by...
Likes.
and go from there...
Alright!
Everybody ready?
I like that the "boob" one is actually highly rated!
Here we go!
What the fuck???
Sh-- Am I allowed -- I don't know if I'm allowed to touch that!
AHHHH!
I am!
OOHHH!
OH THATS CO-- ah fuck!
Alright hang on.
Ha!
WHOOO!
HA!
Oh that's cool!
Oh that's actually cool!
ooo!
ah!
OOO!
AH!
OOOOOO!
NAAAAHHHH!
FFFFFFUUUUUUUUUCK ME!
auuaaaaAHHHHH!
WHOA! HEY!
I made it!
HO
Gah! FUCK go -- god dammit!
Ha!
uuaaahhhhnnn
tittiessss
I like
Titties
oh ok
eh!
Ah fuck, I'm trying dude!
I'm trying!
EUAHH I'M TRYING!
UEH!
NOOOOO!
Fuck
Don't ask me how I failed on that last one
I have no ideaaaahhh
ahhhh I have no idea...
NYEH!
NEUUHHHHH!
UNH
BAHHH!
Ok I did it
Hup
Boink!
Okay.
Ball
Baaaauuul
AHHHHH!
Ho god!
It's so dangerous!
UH UH
AH
JUMP!
UAHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!
COME ON!
Hell yeah!
Now we're gettin' it!
Oh now we're gettin' it!
Oh now we're really gettin it!
OOOOOHHHHH
SHITTY TITS!!!
AHHHHHHH NOOOOOOOOO
I CAN MAKE IT BACK!
I can make it back!
whoaoaoaoaoa
*Mark's mating call*
(This one is REALLY pretty)
I shoul-- *car crash*
*Mark is astonished*
AM I DEAD?
I'm gonna go get the -- NAH that's probably cheating!
Right? It's probably cheating.
I'm gonna get the DASH that seems --
*high pitched* that seems legitimate!
I could dash.
That see-- That seems good enough!
I mean if I had the grappling hook that would definitely be cheating!
*suspiciously says* and I ain't not cheater...
huhaheha
Let me try to do it legitimately and I'll just do this --
HUOHH GOD
OH GOD OH GOD
AHH FUCK
*childish crying*
I can get through all of this in one go.
I know I can...
Whoop!
I just gotta--
YEESSSSSS!
AHHH!
OOOOHHH NO!
How are you able to do that?
No one's gonna be able to do that!
That's IMPOOSSSIBLEEE!
Hup!
Hubidoop!
uahh!
That's jiggly (puff?)
It's jiggly!
Okay.
OHHHH!
I see it!
There's platforms in between 'em!
How am I gonna be able to do that?
ah!
AWWWWWWWWWWW!!!!
NOT
LIKE
THAT!
Oh boy OH BOY!
DAAAAAUUHHH FUCK YOU!
I'M STILL HERE!
Holy Shit!
Okay.
Up and ovaaarrr!
Okay!
Up an--
ahhhhwwwwww
Am I just supposed to--
I'm just supposed to jump and not, not run for it on that one
And and and and
eh -- IN the thing that--
Fuck. nuengheah
Hup!
BLUHP
Okay.
So I'm just--
WUUUAAAAHHHHH
NOOOOOOOO!!!!!!
*Angry exhale*
*Exhale turns into singing*
*Exhale turns into singing*  ♪ I HAAAATE MY LIFE ♪
*dissapointed*
*Mark becomes car*
BEEP!
Okay! So I just gotta...
Yump!
and go forward.
UH!
Yump!
UAAHHH!
AHHHH!
oookkkaayy...
Here comes the
BIG GUNS!
BOOP!
AWWWHHHHHHHH!
(VICTORY IS MARK'S!)
Mario
Fuckin Mario really?
Oh my god.
Is -- is this Mario?
Oh guh-- Oh
Ahhhh no my
*chuckles*
MY RIDE!
OUUUOOOHHHHHH
Holy shit!
DAAAAA What the fuck ha--
I dabnuh
Nyeh!
Huop!
I can't fuckin --
How?
Wher-- da wha
fu--
Daaaa okay...
GUAHH!
CAN'T CATCH ME!
aww ;--;
MARIO!
Mario!
This reminds me of the first person Mario that uh,
Rocket Jump did.
Like,
Back in the day -- AYE
KE UH BACK IN THE DAY!
AWWW
FFFFFFFFFFFF
FUDOOD
Oh it got CAUGHT!
Awwww I got dead
Hup BAH
What the --
WHA-- WHY DIDN'T YOU
BIAAAAAAHHHHHHHHH
Alright.
HUAHHHH!
Awwwwwwwww
Maybe it would be better to have the double jump than this one.
Why?
Imma get the double jump.
Cause Mario can double jump right?
He a ho!
HE A HO
WHY A HO?
WHYYYYYY?!?!?
He a HOOO!
He a he a ho!
He a--
Fuck this shit.
Okay.
WHYYYY?
It doesn't make any god damn sense!
I don't get what this material is,
But it's not,
it's not authorized
TRACK MATE- Fuck :(
HEEUUUUU!
HUUAAHHH!
aw COME ON!
How did I do it before?
wha-- chaah
I wasn't such an idiot before I bet.
Habooski!
Ok.
HA!
Okay!
Ha huh
Fucky
OOOOOHHHHHH
Fuck!
EH!
EEYUH!
GOOOO!
ok.
NAH!
HAAW
Ha AHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Fucking god dammit!
oooook
I need to just go around that one.
Hup!
FRABER!
Fucking fu--
Almost had that one.
heh
GUHP
RAAAH! I can't go back
I need to look back
That's what I need to do.
Why aren't I looking back?
Ah
AH
UH!
UHHH
YES!
AHHHHH!
FUCK FUCK
NOOOOOOOOO!!!
WHERE IN TH--
OH GOD
Ok!
Alright!
Okay!
This is fine.
(Is it?)
Oh fuck.
WHHHHAAAAAATTT?!?!?!
YOU LIED TO ME!
YOU
LIED
TO
ME!
I'm going back for the dash...
Hup!
*Mark sings a little song*
Ow.
Not where I'm supposed to be!
AH
eh
OH!
WHY?!
Goombas have pointy dicks.
euhh
Nuoh!
FUCK
YOU!
Hup
BOOOOOOOO!
Yes yes yes
YES!
Okay...
Wha-- Why?
What is-- What is this?
Ok.
Alright
Ok!
I got this!
HABOOSKIIIIII
AHHHHH TURN LE--
NAAAAAAA
Fuck you
Habooski!
Ok.
God damn stop that!
Stop that.
That's so weird because
the problem is when you
are touching it and you jump.
You're like sticky to it.
So you don't really jump.
Ok I gotta make this.
EH
Oh yes!
Ok.
So!
AH!
This is gonna be a bitch!
"Grab the coin."
I don't know if I wanna do that!
ok
eh
Oh boy.
HEUAH--
AWWWWW
I CAN'T MOVE TO THE RIGHT AND LEFT ENOUGH!
OOOHHH FUCK YOU!
So I gotta grab the coin...
but I'm just gonna wait until
Boink
Hup
BEAhuuuhh
beeaaaAAA NOOOO!
Ok.
Just gotta--
A WHA
WHY DID IT PUSH ME OFF?!?!?!
IT
PUSHED
ME
OFF!
WHYYYY???
*car once again*
Yes!
Okay.
Whhaaa
Oh boy oh--
Oh boy!
OH BOY!
*tarzan*
AWWWWWHHH
ITS ITS ITS ITS ITS
APPEARING!
So I just gotta immediately jump.
Wup
So jump--
WHA IT
IT DOESN'T HELP IF I MISS IT
FUCK!
Huh
Gah!
Uh
AHHHHHHH
YES!
YEEEEEEEEESSSSSS!
YYEEEEEHEHEHESSS!
I GET TO PLAY THE
BOOB
LEVEL!
I WANT TO PLAY THAT ONE NOW!
Doesn't seem to be loading...
Pretty sure it broke!
OK!
Vomit in the ball pit is a level that doesn't load.
Imma play Truck Cannons
'cause it sounds cool.
nyyeeeiii
I didn't do it right
K.
Oh now we're gonna work!
WEEEEEEEE!
Did it!
So what am I supposed to do?
and where are the truck cannons?
And why--
*confusion*
Did I hear a truck cannon?
No?
*More confusion*
Ohhhhhhhh!
uuuuuhhhhhhh.....
That's not good!
oooohhhhh
NOOOOO!
AH!
Hey-- okay
Well I am fucked aren't I?
UH!
I can't--
How do I--
uh...
oh.
I can't do that!
What?
Hello Truck!
(Hi c:)
uuuaaaAAHHHH!
Boink!
Wha-- Fuck
I rolled off the wheels.
I think it said something about "Use levitate"
but I don't think I have levitate as a power.
What is "levitate'?
"Let's the player levitate"
OH WOW I GUESS THAT IT THEN!
We're gonna do that one!
'Cause apparently that's what we need to make truck cannons WORK.
Ok this time I'm not gonna be caught off guard.
Boink
Hurp
*airplane*
Boink
mmmmm
nnnnnnnnnn
boin--
HIIIIYYAAAAA
I wish I had levitate before,
levitate is awesome!
Ok I'm missing my ride!
Hooooly shit!
GIMME A RIDE!
SOMEBODY!
HIT ME!
GOD DAMMIT
NOT LIKE THAT!
I'm gonna go backwards!
Where am I--
awwwwwwwwww
Well I--
Oh I mean--
I mean technically I'm still going
just in the wrong direction...
Wha--Where--
What the--
SIR!
SIR?
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
Alright then
I guess we're riding off into the sunset.
So
It's as good a place to end it as any
but I'll see where this journey takes me  but
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought of this and if you want more
down in the comments below!
And as always
I will see you
in the next video.
Buh - bye!